a Missouri agency has tried to register
a fetus as an employee if you really
believe that a fetus is a person
at conception
then it kind of does make sense as I've
talked about before if indeed a fetus is
a person a pregnant undocumented
immigrant shouldn't be able to be
deported because there is a U.S citizen
in her womb if a fetus is a person you
should be able to start collecting child
support if you break up during a
pregnancy okay you get where this is
going passports Etc what we know of
course is that for political reasons and
political purposes there's a movement
that says a fetus is a person but when
it really comes down to what that would
mean in making that a reality all of a
sudden they want to look the other way